this is jonathan ferguson keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and
today he's returning to valve's
legendary shooter franchise
counter-strike to check out more of the
series iconic firearms hmm okay so the
the cs go version of the deagle is
looking pretty good but the first thing
i notice is the the markings which are
basically real rather than legally
different are mirrored onto the other
side of the slide she's a little curious
if you're a fan of counter strike make
sure to check out our previous episode
on the franchise and if there are any
other games guns mechanics that you guys
want to see jonathan break down let us
know in the comment section below right
over to jonathan
revolvers gotta have a revolver in well
any game descended from half-life needs
to have a magnum revolver in my view
regardless of how realistic that is and
of course we've got one faction who can
basically in theory buy whatever weapons
they want so what the heck the latest
version of counter strike has a
modernized revolver with a picatinny
rail on the top well not really a muzzle
weight again it's a rail adapter on the
front this is one of the smith and
wesson performance center models based
on the old school series of revolver
frames those haven't really changed but
the the barrel profile the ability to
mount red dot sights on there once upon
a time you'd have needed a custom mount
to achieve that
and with modern revolvers this type of
revolver anyway uh you have a standard
picatinny rail on the top which changes
up the looks for the player as well and
lets you use
a scope there's always been something
about a scoped revolver again thinking
back to that half-life magnum that was
quite the revelation in 1998
the fanning of the hammer not really
necessary it's a double action revolver
as shah has demonstrated in the
animation with a weirdly sort of
clockworky ratchety sound which you
wouldn't normally hear i'd worry if you
could hear the lock work of a revolver
clacketing away as you pull the trigger
uh i mean if you put your ear next to it
you'll hear it but
speaking of putting guns near your head
um
spinning it around the finger not
recommended not only is it sort of
pointless and the risk is you've dropped
the thing but uh
spinning it in that way means you're
pointing the thing at yourself whilst
putting pressure on the trigger and if
you were stupid enough to do it sorry
extra stupid enough to do it with the
hammer cocked in single action mode well
you've got a very good chance of
shooting yourself or at least someone
behind you but i understand the impulse
to depict a revolver in old west style
if you're going to do that though i
probably would have gone for something
like a
red hawk or some
modern magnum take or bfr maybe uh
modern magnum take on the old-school
single action army and then the fanning
would be worthwhile it would look very
cool and spinning around the finger
would be a bit safer in theory i know
it's a game you're not gonna hurt
yourself but
oh yes the trademark fingerless gloves
and impeccable manicure of a terrorist
so we have two variants of the imi or
iwi galil here the first one brings back
very fond memories of back when i played
counter strike which is pre go so that
was the the old school galil which i've
hastily grabbed an example from the
collection it happens to be a
self-loading variant but it's in
counter-strike trim if you like of
course we've got our mirrored issue with
counter-strike that we've covered before
when we get to global offensive though
that's been fixed and so is the galil
because by this point the galil has a
left side cocking handle in its ace
configuration which is the version that
they've moved to in the modern iteration
of the game more piccadilly rails more
ergonomics including left side cocking
handle with a sort of spring-loaded dust
cover that but gets barged out of the
way by the cocking handle not in theory
ideal opening up the receiver to
dirt and debris but in theory the uh the
cover will will protect it and it means
you don't have to flip the rifle over
mind you the galil was probably wrong on
this
off the cuff the first aka derivative to
have such an easily grasped over-the-top
cocking handle it's not actually a
problem
to operate the cocking handle from the
left side
the rate of fire on the on the original
is astonishingly high um i haven't fired
bursts from a gleal but
it seems far too high to the point where
the sound effects fall over themselves
so even even playing it as a
younger person
struck me as a bit too bit too high um
much slower with the ace i don't know if
they may have over corrected there but
mp5s got a lot of mp5s this one is it
might be my sound system here but bit
too bassy bit too machine gunny it's
difficult one to to get right because
you don't want it like the original
half-life mp5 which is amazing for the
time don't get me wrong but it sounded a
bit like a sort of sewing machine this
is maybe too much like i don't know
almost sounds like a 50 cal machine gun
or something albeit at a mp5 appropriate
rate of fire
i do like the
cs go write up for the mp5 often
imitated but never equaled i'm sure some
people would argue with that but uh
it'll always be the best submachine gun
in my book the write up for this gun
said it was whisper quiet and um well i
think that would be hyperbole at the
best of times but even in the game it's
not it's it's still quite loud and
punchy and if you're ever going to
depict a gun as quietly
clackating away to itself
it would be the mp5 sd that integrated
suppressor and well just makes the round
subsonic as we've commented here before
and almost all you can hear really is
the bolt clattering back and forth there
will be a small pop at the
end of the suppressor as well but it is
very very quiet whisper quiet maybe not
but quieter than this i would suggest
another staple of classic counter strike
the
sg552
but we do have a bonafide e
552
552-2 commando to be precise which i
believe is the version of the 552 that
counter-strike was depicting
very short barrel this uh trumpet
four-prong flash hider i think is
what's on there as well yeah the only
difference is it's depicted
here with a rail on the upper uh and
there is a railroad later railed version
of it we have the old school
70s 80s one in fact this example is
serial number
207 0 207 so in the scheme of things
pretty early
not a very common weapon to be depicted
in games
but quite a cool one
now we recently did another series of
guns from the game squad and there was
an fn minime in that
this being an m249 us service version of
the minime it's the same gun
and i i said at the time that
most video games that adapt the minime
treat it as a sort of rambo gun and it's
just like a very like like an assault
rifle on steroids really not sort of
depicted like a true light machine gun
would be
which squad did do well here we are
as if to prove my point here is your
classic generic video game lmg often
based on the on the minime as this one
is you know nicely modelled for the for
the
technology level that we're talking
about can't fault it too much except
that the it's missing the two catches or
that you pinch at the back to lift the
top cover open this guy just rips the
top cover open
and slams it shut and it stays shut the
rate of fire is there the portability is
there can't really fault it within the
confines of counter-strike but it does
nicely contrast with how the minime is
depicted in a game-like squad
the second time i've seen my mug sprayed
onto the wall of a of a video game
thanks i guess
so we're looking at the cs go model here
improved in in various aspects the
barrel looks a little skinny maybe we've
got some wear overall that looks pretty
good it's definitely uh
clearly much more detailed than the
original couple of incarnations what we
do though in the reload animation
because this version of the game
correctly tracks ammunition is we see
the weapon getting cocked which wouldn't
happen in the first two versions of
counter-strike because it doesn't track
ammunition in that way either the weapon
is always cocked when you change
magazines or it's not cocked at all
because it never reaches that point i
suppose
wow i've forgotten how um shotguns and
counter strike kind of sound like
artillery pieces relative to everything
else real sort of thunderous rolling
boom going on there not particularly
like a real shotgun but
but kind of impressive so this is this
uh benelli super 90 so it'll be it would
be an m4 super 90 i believe but the
shape of the receiver is quite strange i
don't know if that's some real world
modification that i'm not familiar with
or if they've just changed up the design
i don't know but that big log on the
bottom of the receiver is what's
throwing me off and it's still
flipped
so it's ejecting its empties to the left
cocking handle is on the left hey it's a
semi-automatic shotgun does the job
so this counter-strike source version of
the fam ass got me thinking because my
first thought was oh that doesn't look
quite right for a famous but i think
what i'm seeing is a very good
effort within the source engine
to replicate the actual famas the
problem for them was
how
rounded a lot of the contours on this
rifle actually are it's actually quite
sort of smooth and melty looking
um look at it up close whereas the the
model has a lot of very straight edges
on it and is somewhat simplified so i
think they've looked at all the right
cues as it were but the end result ends
up looking wrong because
there isn't the curvature there aren't
there aren't the constant curves
uh to depict i'm trying to show you what
i mean so fold the fold we hold down one
of the bipod legs
this angle here
and here this is all very smooth and and
flowing into the lines of the rifle
whereas the 3d model is
with very crisp edges that just don't
exist on the real object
right um good effort on the deagle i
think
lots of nice shine on there proportions
look good the way it handles it recoils
perhaps roughly what you would expect
for a big ball pistol like this it does
however suffer from what i'm now gonna
from what i'm now dubbing automatic
slide lock syndrome
asls
in which no matter what the state of the
weapon when you go to reload it the
slide magically goes to the rear we've
seen this before we probably won't see
it again not at least not for games post
dating 2022 i would hope a bit of a
shortcut in the reload animation process
i guess and only something that gun
nerds would notice and there were fewer
of us back then
[Music]
hmm okay so the the cs go version of the
deagle is looking pretty good but the
first thing i notice is the the markings
which are basically real rather than
legally different are mirrored onto the
other side of the slide she's a little
curious we've got a lot of straight
edges on this as well but overall you
know it's it's recognizably the desert
eagle to be fair the real thing also has
a lot of straight edges on it
funnily enough i wonder if the earlier
desert eagle was actually a bit small
proportionally because this looks better
this looks more realistic and sure
enough we have that modern
thumbs forward grip extra important with
the desert eagle because the recoil is
significant
and if you jack bauer teacup that thing
your grip is rubbish
not recommended we've also got the
over-the-top cocking action if you like
rather than the slide release it's funny
how fashion dictates some of this stuff
that style of pullback slide and release
was popularized by the magpul guys got a
decade ago or so and it's still used
today does have the advantage that you
can operate any self-loading pistol
using that without having to know where
the slide release is located necessarily
if it's a totally new pistol to you and
you don't have to sort of awkwardly
reach for it and apply the right amount
of pressure the slide release on the
desert eagle requires a lot of thumb
pressure to release so the reliable
consistent way to release a slide from
slide lock having replaced the magazine
of course otherwise it's not going
anywhere
is that over the top grasp
right five seven um i don't remember
this being an old school counter strike
but i spent most of my time pre 1.6
that's how old i am so
not the greatest looking video game gun
ever i think the limitations of the
graphics engine are just too much for
the complexity of this design
lots of edges and curves and angles and
fine details
and by attempting to depict them
it comes off looking very busy and
almost misshapen it's like the it's too
narrow the the reload it's like they're
trying to jam a magazine that's too big
for the gun into the grip which to be
fair isn't far off the the magazine on
the 5.7 is almost as wide front to back
as the gun is
um but it's almost clipping through
the gun i'm now looking at the cs go
version and needless to say two
generations on things have improved
greatly i can nitpick this thing uh if
we had the time the checkering on the on
the front strap isn't quite right some
of the angles aren't quite right i'm not
gonna go to town on it it's recognizably
an fn57
right mp7 now the one i've grabbed is an
ex-police model so as well as some rack
numbers it has
only semi-automatic because uk police
do not use automatic fire now there are
a couple of different flavors of mp7
floating around um so we allow a little
bit of artistic license depending on
whether it's a an early a1 a later a1 or
an a2 but there are yeah there are a few
minor issues with this
the way that the front grip is depicted
it should hinge higher up on that
mounting log there is a weird hole
underneath the fire selector so
when i move that there should be solid
polymer there on this model there's what
looks like a hole through the receiver
which doesn't quite look right anyway we
could we could go on let's see how it
plays
yeah i mean proportionately compared to
the other guns in the game it behaves
as you'd expect sounds a bit muffled
muted almost like it's suppressed but it
isn't the cartridge cases flying out
look to be standard pistol cases not the
five seven case that it should be and
it's a little bit too controllable
considering the stock is never extended
it's all it's almost it shoots pretty
much like the stock is in the shoulder
which it isn't
you have gone with only three right g3
sg1 i have one here or at least g3sg1
configuration which is one of several
accurized
hnk g3 rifles but stock with a cheat
piece
claw mount for a relatively high power
scope this one is actually marked up as
something else g3fs i think it may have
been built as an sg1 latterly we do have
a gun marks g3 sg-1 in the royal
armouries collection but it doesn't have
a scope and a mount so i grabbed this
for you only real thing to say it kind
of functions as a semi-auto sniper or
really what it is more than a dmr pretty
much functions as you'd expect i don't
know why they went to green furniture
because i've never seen one of these
with green furniture but you could you
could find a set of green furniture and
change it out i guess although the stock
is sort of specific to this it's it's
kind of hard to
to criticize beyond that
within the limitations of the game
it works as it as it should i think it's
safe to say which is to say you can use
it like a battle rifle semi-automatic
from the from the hip because you kind
of have to do one or the other there's
no backup sights to let you
use it like a more powerful close
quarters rifle as it were and then you
zoom to the scope for longer distance
absolutely
standard
game stuff
okay we've got a bit of a funky looking
ar-15 here the proportions
don't look right
buffer tube is too small the lower
receiver is an odd shape especially the
fence as we call it around the magazine
catch is a bit odd looking dust cover is
just flat which is weird normally
there's a texture on that the receiver
is too deep at the back
pistol grip's an odd shape i don't know
what's going on with the selector there
the handguard looks like one version of
the ar-15 or m4 handguard there aren't
any grooves seemingly in the picatinny
rail on the top and the flashlight
doesn't look quite right either yeah
it's all a little bit out of whack the
butt stock itself compared to the buffer
tube is huge
yeah not the most successful rendition
i've ever seen an m4a4 well there isn't
an m4a4 um
let's see
okay we've got a good reload there the
drop the magazine free insert and you
want slap the vault release that's all
good the selector on the left hand side
is correct it's the weird black empty
thing on the right i don't understand
that almost looks like a mistake and i
can now see the the stop bridges on the
picatinny rail so that must have been
the angle i was looking at yeah it may
be a bit generic as video game guns go
but then hey the ar-15 is generic as
real guns go
as always if you'd like to donate to us
you can do that via the description
otherwise check out our various royal
armory social media platforms the
websites and ideally if you can the
museums as well they're well worth a
look
see you next week guys
[Music]
you